so it's a pretty mixed fuse there in
Edinburgh well to dust discuss all this
and more I'm joined in a studio now by
the First Minister of Scotland in class
tajen thank you for being with us this
morning
so back in 2014 we were all told that
the independence referendum was a
once-in-a-generation event so I'm a
little bit confused just how long do you
think a generation is I think that's a
reasonable question of course brakes
have changed everything in 2016 and if
we cast our minds back to the 2014
referendum what we were also told by
those campaigning against independence
at that time was that a yes vote would
jeopardize a place in the European Union
and only a new vote would secure it so
the 2016 vote on the EU really was a
material change in circumstances the
future of the UK looks very different
today than it did two years ago in my
argument is it's quite a simple one we
know as a result of the brakes of all
changes coming for Scotland we can't
avoid that change now the question is
what kind of changed do we warn and
shouldn't we have the right to choose
that do we want to go down the hard
bricks a path or do we want to choose
independence so that we can create that
genuine partnership of equals across the
British Isles but also secure a
relationship with Europe so it's a bit
choice it's about saying to people the
future of Scotland really should be
decided by Scotland not decided for us
by Westminster governments you see about
your whole argument on the fact that
there's been a change in circumstances
that has a brexit that was in page 23 of
your referendum and but at the same time
it does feel a little bit like you're
trying to catch people out with the
small print because what you have also
been saying very strongly is that you
won't have another referendum until it's
clear the majority of Scottish people
want it I'm just going to look for
example at what you said when you were
launching your manifesto in 2016 setting
the date for a referendum before a
majority of the Scottish people have
been persuaded independence is the best
future for our country is the wrong way
around and there hasn't been a single
poll that shows that the case of China I
may be an old-fashioned tea I don't
think manifestos our small print the
manifesto that I was elected on as First
Minister incidentally with the higher
sheet of the vote across Scottish
constituencies of any party in the
history of the Scottish Parliament is
really important and what it said and
you
korte both of those bits of the
manifesto a me but what it said was the
Scottish Parliament should have a rate
of another referendum if that is a
significant change in opinion or if
there is an Italian about the emphasis
that you chose to make when you're
standing on the stage it's the same
emphasis that you made for example when
launching the manifesto and also in
those Holyrood TV TV might debates as
well my manifest or speaks for itself in
anybody can go and look at the terms of
the manifesto I was elected on and that
is you know yes we said if there was a
material shift in opinion or and the
wonder horror was there if there is a
material change in circumstances and it
expressly it said such as Scotland been
taken out of the EU against our will and
we were elected fili overwhelmingly on
the strength of that manifesto but like
I'm making an argument everybody knows
that support independence I don't think
I'm telling you anything you don't know
bit no secret no explicit for you yeah
but this is about choice and you know
people in Scotland decide that hard
bricks that the weighted easily wants to
take the UK is for Scotland one that's
one thing but they're highly known as
those people that want that choice is
there and what I would actually suggest
that that is only saying I mean there's
been there's been a slew of opinion
polls over the the past week you know
there was one showing that a majority of
people did think if the Scottish
government said there should be a
referendum then the UK government should
not stand in the way there's been no or
one thing that the majority of Scotia
people want independence which is what
you were talking about well I launched
your manifest I've said what my
manifesto says and you know anybody can
be don't have to just listen to me you
can go and check that and the mandate
from the choice I'm seeking to give
people notice is very clear it's beyond
any shadow of a doubt but on the
question of of public opinion I guess
what I'm seeing is it should be for
people to choose because we know that
breaks that means change now is
inevitable it's about what kind of
change did we want and who gets to
decide that if a referendum or an
independence was to be denied then
effectively the future of Scotland has
not been decided by us it's been decided
for us no I should say I don't propose a
referendum
no I don't think it would be right to
put that choice to the people of
Scotland before the the terms of breaks
that were cleared are much much clearer
than they are no but I also think it
would be fair for people in Scotland
once
terms are clear to have that choice
before it's too late to choose a
different call let's talk about that
timetable shower because two resumes
made it pretty clear that she doesn't
accept the timetable you've put on at
the table which is biotin 2018 no no
it's not it's the earliest autumn 20 the
earliest autumn 2018 would you accept
her on table which is off I don't know
what our timetable is I mean after
breaks it could be from no to never you
know by definition but shall we say what
after the breaks that negotiations after
the UK so let me again be happy so how
about a friend of that I guess that
depends on what that timeframe there
looks like I've said in a snit again
well let me just say my position clearly
I say just study if Judy's amis concern
this time angling within reason I'm
happy to have that discussion
I tried trying to find some consensus
here we both say not know so we agree on
that I've said to the time frame that I
think would be fair and reasonable she
says she doesn't agree with that so I
think it's therefore hard to see what
time frame she thinks would be
reasonable and then might have that
discussion I'm perfectly happy to have
that discussion so we're 12 is thank you
be okay know that that teacher to the
second point I was I was going to make I
don't think it would be fair for
Scotland to have a delay so that it
meant that Scotland was taken out of the
EU a long long period of time was
allowed to elapse making it much harder
than for Scotland even if it wanted to
to negotiate a different relationship
with Europe that's why I talked about
this you know before it's too late for
us to choose a different course so you
know I'm perfectly I've tried very very
hard to compromise with cities and me
over the past number of months I mean
what viewers outside of Scotland may not
be aware of is that we actually put
forward a proposal that would have
accepted Scotland staying in the UK
coming out of the EU but protecting over
police within the single market at
proposing new powers for the Scottish
Parliament to try to protect Scotland's
interests in a post breaks at landscape
so we've tried really hard to compromise
and we've made so far with a UK
government that's been very intransigent
and not willing to enter them to that
discussion part of tourism a concern of
course will be that this is not the
right thing to be hanging over those
crucial negotiations now I understand a
call
you represent people in Scotland do you
not care at all yes are the instability
about other people in the UK people from
England Wales I do care deeply I didn't
want the UK to be in this position at
all
I want the UK to get a good deal from
Europe because that apart from being in
the best interests of people in other
parts of the UK that's also could be a
distraction from that deal but I cannot
and I'm not alone here I cannot simply
pretend that I don't have real fears
that Theresa May will not get a good
deal she may get a bad deal or no deal
and the even a good deal will be
significantly worse than membership of
the single market so this comes to the
choice I had to be cakung you know
choose to let Scotland simply drift
through the next two years crossing my
fingers you know hoping for the bass
while you're feeling the worst or I can
try to say a plan for Scotland though
that gives at the right time the people
of Scotland a choice and I think it's
right to plan to give people in Scotland
the choice okay well let's talk about
that plan shall we an independent
Scotland in your mind would you be
looking to join the EU as a full desert
you would that's long-standing SNP
policy even though it's so complicated
in order to get to that application all
you need is one member state to say no
that's no good such as Spain there it is
and you be at the back of the key with
you except there's a waiting list that
is there is no queue to join the
European Union and we've had you know
several voices over a recent time saying
that if Scotland wanted to be in the EU
there would be a very open warm
reception for that now I accept that we
haven't changed circumstances in 2014
when we were I was out in the case but
independence the UK was very firmly in
the EU the UK is now going to be coming
out of the EU so we have to and set out
really clearly to people in Scotland
before asking them to make this choice
the the route of the process that we
would take to transition from where we
are now to being in a relationship with
Europe that was right for Scotland so
you know that's detail that requires to
be set out but I do believe it's right
for Scotland to remain within that
European family of Nations not instead
of trading across the UK but in addition
to that the single market is massively
important it's massively important to
the UK economy it's very important to
the Scottish economy geographically we
are you know on the periphery of Europe
it's really important to be in the
single market it's important for
investment and for jobs to you know
protect the the rates of ourselves to
follow careers or jobs in other European
countries and vice versa it's important
for all of these reasons so yes I do
think that is important it's also what
people in Scotland voted for you say the
thing Amara is important of course it is
important but 63 percent of Scottish
trade is with the rest of the UK and
that compares just 16 percent with the
EU I mean the real risk would be losing
questions and you've come on to that
donator in a second but yeah I
absolutely accept the scrutiny of these
positions because if you think about the
brakes of what people would ask to vote
with no detail whatsoever name Mansour
and it still breaks it means breaks it
is about as much detail as we've got
it's a leap into the dark a bit like my
friend Earl and an animal I'm determined
that it wouldn't be it would be an
informed choice which is why I see the
choice should happen when the terms of
breaks that are clear and also the
obligation is on me and those arguing
for independence to put forward the
detail on what independence looks like
to come back to creation because I
wasn't trying to dodge it and the trait
of the you keep trigger the rest of the
you key is important for Scotland
vitally important for Scotland it's
important for the rest of the UK to
trade with Scotland I'm not proposing
staying in the single market instead of
that treat and for those who see or but
it would be impossible to treat an
independent Scotland to trade with the
UK at meet two points we've got a UK
government seeing that it's going to
freely trade with every country in the
world would be a bit odd if that
excluded and independent Scotland but
secondly you know the Prime Minister
rightly I should say I absolutely agree
with the comment she meets in this
regard is seeing right now to the
Republic of Ireland that the UK being
out of the EU and the Republic of
Ireland being in it does not necessitate
a hard border between Ireland and the UK
and would not put in place by leaders to
treat I simply make the point that it's
not credible for the UK government to
see that to Ireland and independent
in the EU and to somehow retain that the
situation would be different for an
independent Scotland so what currency
then would an independent scholar this
we would do no piece of what looking at
this just know obviously in 2014 we
proposed using the pound within a
currency union the starting point of our
consideration is it Scotland would use
the pound that's our currency it's a
fully treatable international currency
but as I'm sure you know I have a good
author commission right now looking at a
plan for the economic future of Scotland
but also looking in detail at currency
options for school so you don't know
then
well then calling for a referendum when
you're not sure what currently is that
Commission hasn't concluded its what yet
I'd be perfectly frank look a referendum
at the earliest is going to be 18 months
from now I absolutely accept well in
advance of that not just in currency but
on the economic plan on some of the
questions you're asking me on Europe we
will set a very clear proposition I
think it's right given the change
circumstances of brexit that we do very
serious work before we come to putting
that proposition forward so that what
hasn't concluded yet I said in my speech
to the SNP conference yesterday it will
conclude over the next few months and at
that point we will publish its
conclusions for public scrutiny and
debate and people I feel your few people
have said commentators have said that
laws of is arguing for independence next
time round with tightest of emulate the
leave campaign by putting slogans on the
side of a bus and given no detail I
would not want the future of my country
to be decided on that basis I want
people in Scotland to have an informed
choice and that means informed about the
implications of breaks it but also
informed about the implications of
Independence but it's not say what
currency oh jeez I mean it's so quick I
really that was something you should
wash that for boiling for a referendum
and before going to the very length
times we've just been talking about is
that the earliest 18 months away I'm not
asking people to vote today or tomorrow
or next week or next month but what I've
said is we're doing detailed what the
starting point of our consideration is
that Scotland uses the pound it's
currency as much as it is the currency
of anywhere else but it's rate would
unfairly change circumstances breaks it
changes lots and lots of things not just
for Scotland but for the UK so I think
people should take some assurance from
the fact that we're doing very detailed
work on all of these questions and well
in advance have been asked to make a
choice there will be a proposition put
forward for people that allow them to
meet that choice in a very informed way
let's talk about the economic realities
because Scotland has a 15 billion pound
deficit now as a percentage of GDP that
is higher than any other EU member state
including Greece your economy is growing
at a third of the speed of the rest of
the United Kingdom oil revenues in the
last two years have fallen by 97% be
frank can Scott have really afford to
become an independent country well I
would actually look at that and perhaps
some people would look at that and
seeking it's got and afford not to be
because that deficit and I wanted yeah
because again these are all absolutely
legitimate questions and that deficit is
one that has been created on to use
shorthand Westminster's watch that's not
a feature of life in an independent
Scotland that's what's happened with
Scotland as part of the UK but you've
been in government you need to take some
responsibility as well don't you we're
not responsible for macroeconomic policy
in the Scottish Parliament I wish we
where we might not be in that position
and of course the UK and most countries
have a deficit and the UK's got what 1.7
trillion pounds of debt which is
separate to deficit obviously but that's
my first point the second point unless I
think is the more fundamental point that
deficit exists whether we then dependent
or not which means that has to be dealt
with for the real independent or not the
question there therefore for Scotland is
are we better to allow Westminster to
keep making the same mistakes that
created that deficit in the first place
or are we better to say to an economic
plan about how we use the greater
economic powers of Independence to grow
our economy to encourage more people to
come to Scotland which if we're in the
single market in the UK is not I suspect
would be a bit of a magnet for
investment to work out a plan to get a
more sustainable and stronger economic
future then that's the fundamental
choice the deficit can't be magic - we
wherever a constitutional future it's
what constitutional arrangements give us
the best
to deal with that situation so you blame
Westminster at the same time you get a
twenty six billion pound block grant
from Westminster that's what you what
that's the way we're funded which has
been if you take from the moment the
Tories came to powder to entertain to
the end of this decade that brought
Graham over just by ten percent in real
terms so the Scotland's not independent
and again this was orgies it's nothing
well well no because that that money
goes from Scotland to Westminster and
comes back he kidding suet and we're
getting overly technical here the point
I'm making is that Scotland doesn't
become independent and that's a choice
for people in Scotland then what we're
facing are continued it cuts to our
Block Grant we are facing more years of
austerity we're facing an impact from
the UK leaving the single market that
you know as estimated to you know cost
thousands of jobs in Scotland and to
reduce our budget even further so this
is a choice not between some you know
certain future with no no no
difficulties with the UK and lots of
uncertainty and difficulties with
independence this is a better future
where there are big challenges for
Scotland in the UK how do we best equip
ourselves to meet those challenges and I
think steam within the world's biggest
single market giving ourselves the
ability to work towards a more
sustainable economic future
it's far better than allowing ourselves
to be taken out of that single market by
the UK and facing the economics of
austerity for more years just as we have
over the past number of years there is
an argument isn't there that talking
about an independence referendum it's
quite convenient for you because it
allows you to distract from your
domestic record of the SNP and let's
just look at that record for a second
education standards are slipping a
record number of nations are now doing
better than Scotland in terms of that
life expectancy two years left in the UK
the number of children in poverty is up
the number of pensioners in poverty is
up I mean it's it's a welcome diversion
isn't it from the record of the SNP it
just very briefly I don't think you can
say
you know the health of our NHS in
education which is affected by overall
public spending and budgets from these
big decisions about whether within a row
of a single mark are independent or not
but if you can't blame it all my exams
I was about to comment on these I take
responsibility for all of these things
but I was just going to you know counter
some of these you know we saw poverty in
Scotland and the UK increasing last week
largely down to welfare changes from
Westminster on education we've got a
massive program of work underway right
now to our East and us to cause the
attainment gap we are now seeing
improvements in terms of children from
more deprived backgrounds doing better
than school going to university take the
Health Service for example an accident
and emergency departments under real
pressure in common with others across
the UK are performing 13 percentage
points better than accident emergency
departments in England ninety point
eight percent of people in Scotland seen
within four hours 77 percent in England
so on many of these judgments we are
doing better here in Scotland under the
Scottish Government than policy south of
the borders I take those
responsibilities very very seriously but
I take my waiter responsibilities as
First Minister to try to protect
Scotland's interests in the bigger
picture of your life so that we can
continue to invest in health and
education and continue to work towards
the improvements that all of us want to
see if you're so committed to improving
things such as education why don't you
only mention it once in your speech
yesterday when you mention in the pill
we've got a massive program of work
underway in education right now so we
are you know in the process of
introducing standardized assessments
we've just announced at 120 million
pounds people equity at fun putting
resources directly into the hands of
hate teachers we've got a governance
review of Education under week what I
did talk about my speech yesterday was
the doubling of childcare provision over
this Parliament and our intention to pay
a Chokey of staff who work in our
nurseries the living wage so we can
attract more people into that profession
value that work because we know that
many of the inequities in education
later than a child's education start
before they even start school we've put
such an emphasis on increasing
early years and childcare provision and
that was one of the key announcements in
my speech yesterday as was investment in
mental health so we're going to increase
the access to mental health
professionals not just in our hospitals
but in our prisons and police sales also
announcing investment in my speech
yesterday around digital skills so you
know you can't just I know you don't
didn't know that I'm talking about all
the things that they don't know that
you're working to to stop these were all
in my speech yesterday they're all vital
but all of these things are at risk if
we are learn ourselves to be taken down
that hard breaks at path that is going
to be so damaging for our economy in our
society now I'm really interested in
this question because you are clearly a
formidable politician you've devoted
your life to independence you've built
your reputation over many years this is
a huge personal risk for you it was no
the second referendum if you fail then
just like David Cameron this could be
all day you know yeah I just think a
simple view I'm not in politics to you
know judge everything and what it means
for my own individual kitty okay you
must feel that pressure like any
politician what's the fault what was
worth their salts early Sunday morning
since name it doesn't feel the pressure
to the job shouldn't be in that job so I
feel the pressure I feel far more
pressure to make sure we've got a really
well performing health service and to
fulfill the commitment I've given around
education these are the things that
matter and what asleep what was the
formative thing in Nicholas sturgeons
life that meant you were so committed to
an impact I grew up I grew up with my we
thought she was prime minister in a part
of Scotland in common with with many
communities across England and Wales as
well that you know was really damaged
because of her Industrial Policy because
of her you know approach to meny policy
so I grew up with people who you know
had a sense of hopelessness unemployment
was very high and one of the things when
I was very young that seemed wrong to me
was that all
policies were being imposed on Scotland
when most of vast majority of people in
Scotland had never voted for for
microfractures party so my politics are
driven by social justice and building a
better country independence for me is
not the end in itself it's the means to
an end it's the means to trying to build
a bit of Scotland so will you stand down
than if you knew this referent you know
I'm not planning to Toulouse I'm
planning to give people in Scotland a
choice and I'm planning to try to
persuade them to make what I consider to
be the right choice and you know after
we've had it I'll be perfectly happy to
go back and answer those questions but I
you know you know it's a it's not a
question that I'm good to engage with
right I was hoping you would but never
mind we're not quite no later Nicola
Sturgeon thank you for thank you very
much